you're under arrest both of you is that
a joke how do you feel about the finale
because I was so heartbroken over the
whole poo situation I was really mad by
the finale obviously I wanted Ali to
like be in power but hey you know I
learned a lot from Ali who do you think
she should trust to help her out in this
situation I mean from the show I'm like
trust no one
maybe Grizz I love Grizz I really grids
in her they're gonna come up with
something you know like he's still on
Team Ali I feel like why is she bleeding
what happened while you're gone what do
you think is actually going through his
mind in his heart of hearts he kind of
knows what's going on and that'll be a
point of conflict in the future talk to
a Kathryn Newton earlier and I said who
do you think Ali can trust to get her
out of this situation and she said Chris
oh yeah for sure we're homies to fight
for Ali and a season two oh yeah yes all
hail Khaleesi you die alone you survive
together you know and I think will is
very pragmatist and then you know Ali's
a leader Grizzlies and explorer he's
very like resourceful you know and so
all of them together need to measure
their own strengths yeah and then
utilize each other as a team
in order to survive which is really just
how the world works right
you think Helena has a plan to save Ali
and will she always have a plan Helena
always at the plan yes do you think
helena is still on the good side of
things yeah I mean what is the good side
really like
I think everyone's just acting
impulsively and wants to save themselves
and that's kind of why it's so hot
what's going on it's all right Luke
what's happening I feel like her
relationship with Ops is gonna be very
tested because Luke
ultimately goes to the dark side yeah
how do you think this the finale affects
their relationship right depending on if
we go to season two they have a lot to
work out because they leave on a very
top clip hang on two very disappointed
in Luke with the plan I think because
you know peer pressure a little bit with
his friends we don't know it so we're in
the situation so we're in the room and
we have a conversation or we have a
group of people that are you know about
to beat us up or possibly kill us that
we make a decision so yeah so I feel bad
for him but yeah it's that bad move bad
move Luke I think the story goes in the
season two is there hope that he can
maybe undo what he's done he's in a
tight spot is you know he's in a really
really tight spot but I think that is
absolutely potential for redemption and
for him to set things right and to make
up for what he's done but they promise
you like do you think he feels bad for
what he did to a lien will absolutely
absolutely yeah yeah yeah but he's a kid
you know and I mean even if he wasn't a
kid you know we make bad decisions
sometimes as people
yeah do you want to hear the deal or not
Campbell is really responsible for
overthrowing Ali and putting this land
into motion what do you make of these co
mayors and where things ends my thing
with Campbell was very much if if I'm
able as Campbell to get all these people
to do what I want them to do and they're
so easily manipulative then they're kind
of the same as me
it's like Campbell proving to himself
that all these people I actually have
the same I guess evil inside them as
Campbell does do you think he feels bad
this camel feel bad no I think he's
actually by the end of it he's having a
pretty good time I think the more chaos
that's going on the more Campbell feels
like he's surrounded by I guess
reflected back to him himself from the
way that he feels so I think it's a
win-win for cam
Ali well what did you do to her well
nothing yeah do you think that L has a
plan up her sleeve where do you think
she's saying well I think L is kind of
why I guess she's kind of always had a
plan up her slave to a degree if she
gets pushed into a corner hard enough
she seems to try to find a way out even
if it doesn't become successful it's
right away I'll be inside to see what
happens in the second season have you
talked to the writers at all a little
bit I'm imagining that'll be some kind
of dip in power and that Campbell will
lose power eventually but he regains
that of all you know what happens I
don't know it but I feel like that would
be an interesting place to go who cares
who's in charge this is just a game I
think it's gonna be just very
interesting going into season two like
what happens with all that stuff you
know with the power and do you think
that Harry feels bad at all for what
he's done because him and Ali had a
romance yeah
to be honest I think Harry is very
distracted by the end of the series so
perhaps he's not thinking about too much
about what kind of actions his done
I don't think there's any regret
involved he came into this series with
his dad just dying
and he had a whole life planned for him
and that all crumbled and he's lost he
doesn't know what to do we are not a mop
all right we still have rules here was I
accurate to think that she seemed unsure
of herself when the coup came to be I
think there are always a lot of things
in question but I think that Lexie
always has something up her sleeve at
the core do you think that Lexi's a good
person I think she's got a little bit of
you know good and bad in her yeah
definitely yeah who do you think will
make a better mayor Lexie or Harry don't
tell Harry but I might be as a fan I
love Lexie Dixie I don't know I kind of
want to see what she does like as a
viewer I want to see what kind of chaos
she causes you know anybody would be
funny to watch Harry fail listen to me
everything stays the same I think that
each of them has had you know has has
potential to be great do you think in a
season two
Allie could return to power is there
when I feel like once you get a taste of
power like don't you just want it so I
hope she does but I don't know
[Applause]
you
[Music]